Gwyneth Paltrow is a lady of many talents.
In addition to acting, singing, writing books,
and raising children, she's also now a Marvel
secret spoiler.
"Weak!
So weak."
In an interview with Titan Publishing's Official
Avengers: Infinity War magazine, Paltrow,
who portrays Pepper Potts in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, may have spilled a major spoiler
about Avengers 4.
The actress opened up about her character's
relationship with Robert Downey Jr.'s Tony
Stark -- better known to the world as Iron
Man -- and as it turns out, her scene in Infinity
War might have been a prelude for big news
to come from Stark Tower.
In the beginning of Infinity War, Tony tells
Pepper that he had a dream she was pregnant.
Pepper brushes the comment aside, neither
confirming nor denying whether she's actually
expecting before Tony jets off to the cosmos
to do battle with Thanos.
While Pepper might've been playing coy, Paltrow
didn't hold back.
She seems to tell fans in the magazine feature
that Pepper has not only survived Thanos'
Infinity Gauntlet snap, but that she's also
with child, saying:
"Pepper and Tony have had a really long journey
together.
She obviously starts as his dutiful assistant,
and then the relationship evolves, and now
this decade later they're married, and they
have a child.
Their relationship has evolved in all of the
ways that great romances evolve."
The turn of phrase Paltrow used here still
invites some questions, of course.
By saying the two "have a child," it could
mean that she's pregnant in Avengers 4, which
would mean that the film picks up just after
Infinity War.
Or it could mean that by the time the next
film comes along, she'll have already had
a little one with the billionaire philanthropist
superhero.
"Where's the kid?!"
Of course, the lovebirds could always end
up adopting a child -- since there's bound
to be plenty of orphans left in the wake of
Thanos' snap -- but in either case, it looks
like the Starks will become a party of three
in Avengers 4, somehow.
Considering how protective Marvel is over
their plot details, it's pretty baffling how
Paltrow's remarks here made it to print, but
perhaps the studio just wanted to give fans
a reason to be optimistic after so much devastation
in Infinity War.
"Go team, yeah!"
After all, what better way to say goodbye
to the guy who started it all than to make
him turn a complete 180 from the selfish,
spoiled magnate he once was into a doting
dad who wants to live a humble, quiet life
instead?
Whatever does come of this news, let's just
hope we get some kind of happy ending, and
not the Tony-and-his-son-die-together one
as seen in the comics.
We'll know for sure what Paltrow's mention
of Pepper's secret bun in the oven entails
when Avengers 4 arrives on May 3, 2019.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!